for young managers watching this who um
maybe have an undiscovered talent that
they're trying to break like
whoever it might be whatever city it
might be and what would be advice you'd
give them um formulate a team that's one
like you need a team you need a social
media person
uh social media digital marketing you
need a cameraman you need a producer you
need an engineer you need a pr person
the pr person can come a little bit
later on when is when you need it
formulate a team and start building
create a plan and stick to it don't have
no plan b's believe in god keep it fair
keep it ethical and work don't take
everything on by yourself no it's no
it's impossible yeah it's impossible you
have a team you know what i'm saying you
have people
when pr come when when does because you
know a lot of times i think i see
artists do the pr thing too soon as
needed i would say as needed just like
like cooking you you know you know
at what they say to taste
to taste when needed when when you get
to the point where your faces need to be
seen in your city and you need to be at
every party and you need to be in the
mix you need to know the right [ __ ] then
you get a pr when people are calling
asking for interviews for you and [ __ ]
like that then you need a pr until then
you don't need it but the other things
you need you need a videographer
trailing you every day studio sessions
you need an engineer you need a producer
and um you need a digital marketer and
when after you get to that point you
need a playlister what's a digital
marketer somebody who like you know you
see these things on these websites our
generation uh getting you that those
looks you see you think you should just
happen organically like of course
yeah so there's somebody who has a
relationship with these people they're
kind of like somebody who's to work
radio records at radio that relationship
across the country with the dj's what is
a playlister a playlist is somebody who
helped you get on playlist and i'm
saying have a user curated playlist as
well because user curator playlists are
very important they're kind of like a
100
all these things cost money everything
so save your money what is that a dollar
like of like you know let's say what's
the minimum dollar amount somebody
should like try to save up before they
really start trying to build that [ __ ]
out because that's those aren't cheap
things to put together i mean
you got to maybe you might be able to
get a free videographer
you're starting out that's right that
believes in you right the same with your
engineers same with the producer they
all believe in each playlist and the
digital marketing though
so what's that dollar amount you think
minimum
a good digital guy is going to be at
least
at least
1500 2500 a campaign okay and you're
going to need money to actually give
that person
to run the campaigns you know we're
going to their incentive we're going to
do it we're going to see these videos
out and we're going to do this content
and it's going to cost x amount we're
going to buy this amount of google
play you know what i'm saying so you
need actual money to give that person
will the digital marketer handle your
youtube ads yes okay a good one which is
important yeah true view
true view what's true view trueview is
like the it's like when you see
say a snoop dogg video come on and after
it uh right into it a yg somebody video
come on like something that's very
similar algorithms you want to piggyback
off that algorithm you know what i'm
saying so when you see a high
performing video video that comes right
after it you know what i'm saying that
makes sense
so
we think about five five bands let's say
i want to drop a single if you want to
drop a single you drop a project single
single i say you should have ten
thousand dollars ten thousand ten
thousand dollars and that's
low that's on the low end make sure your
singles mix and mastered make sure you
got money to shoot a decent video you
get a decent video shot for cheap you
know yeah yeah yeah get a decent video
shot for cheap
um
then you need somebody who's gonna work
it at the playlist
level you know what i'm saying
somebody's gonna service it well there
it is
and then another person on the team when
you really you see how your team gets so
big damn why this person got all these
people you need somebody who is gonna
pitch a [ __ ] for saints too the movies
and tvs that's a that's a bag as well a
sync person
the sync thing is uh
because they work off of commission a
lot of them so it's like if they don't
get you nothing yeah if they'll get you
know you're playing nothing but so so
these people you're talking about
if someone's in wichita kansas and they
don't know any how do they f how do you
find these people [ __ ] if you're in
wichita kansas you got to go where these
people are you got to go to new york got
to go to l.a yeah that's like any job
i'm trying to be an actor i'm you got to
get the [ __ ] out of what you're talking
good chance that i'm not going to be
actor in wichita i'm going to have to
move to la or new york to come get
noticed so i mean you take your crabs
seriously you gotta go where the people
are